[Music]
going through the motions cold water
just to get you up different date but
same day music while you walk to fill
your thoughts lecture you don't care
about scroll to hide from your problems
gy but much hasn't changed in months
watch a bunch of men play your dream who
don't even know you exist drink at night
wake up same thing again maybe next time
you'll meet a nice girl you keep hoping
we all go through it whether College
your business a job the Motions grabs us
all at some point that's why I'm hitting
reset no social media nutting nicotine
alcohol THC zero content consumption
plus meditate and read daily back to
zero Fresh Start except I'm the one
grabbing Life by the balls not a ball
dropping where I just pray something
changes congrats on making it this far
on the video no Mr Beast hook or video
game footage to keep you here you want
to change test yourself let's see how
far you can make it in this video as you
watch me hit the reset button fix the
brain and how it goes for me me if you
can't remember nothing changes if
nothing changes on to day one of the
detox so as if a dopamine detox in my
fried brain wasn't enough I decided to
make day one even harder no phone or
devices at all on this day of boredom I
started it off with a nice gym session
definitely a lot easier to focus and
move through it without your phone to
distract you in between lifts after the
pump with nothing else to do I headed
over to Bass Pro got a fishing rod and
decided to be with nature for a bit it's
about 4:00 right now I haven't looked at
my phone all day yeah and it's pretty
crazy this is like my first time going
this late into the day without like
looking at business or social media [__]
because it's just like what my life has
been incapsulated with and like sitting
here [__] fishing and whatnot this
should be something where it's like so
rewarding and peaceful and my brain just
feels like [__] like I just feel so
exhausted and like honestly I'm just
like bored like I recognize that like
scrolling on Tik Tok gives you more of a
dopamine hit than like sitting here and
fishing but uh yeah I'll keep you guys
updated no phone still for the rest of
today and then yeah the rest of the week
is just [__] boring basically like
detention you know like some like back
in middle school when like your mom
would take your video games away cuz you
posted a racist meme or some [__] like
that maybe that only happened to me but
then like all week without your phone
without video games you're stuck at home
just like flipping through random old
books you have and then like finally you
get that [__] back and it's like you can
actually like enjoy it again and you
appreciate every moment you had with it
and that's kind of how I feel right now
with just like all the basic stuff in my
life and even all the bad habits that I
had just like a couple hours of chilling
with the fishies later drove back home
and ran into a friend
downstairs what's up man what the I'm
live right now you guys just fishing
what are you doing look how like dor
these guys like giant fishing rods in
Miami I've never seen this did you catch
anything no was kind of that's funny F
so we just got back to the Miami crib
and I haven't had this in a long [__]
time but like I'm actually excited to
read a [__] book right now Geeks bro
like driving in the car with no music
just your thoughts you realize how much
of the day you're just filling your
brain with garbage and nonsense so being
able to really detach and separate it it
allows you to enjoy the little things so
much more in life and can really
appreciate it you know like right now I
got home usually I would go right to
like looking through Instagram looking
through Twitter all this dumb [__] and
like right now I'm literally going on
the balcony and just I'm just going to
read for a while take a shower and then
probably head to bed early and then just
like get after work again tomorrow but
yeah bro like the the little Habits Like
journaling and all all this stuff it's
just been like it seemed so tedious
lately with the amount of stimulation of
I've been getting living in Miami when
I'm home looking at social media working
all this stuff so like to get a full
reset just feels so [__] good man day
two phone access is regranted strictly
for business of course still zero
dopamine sticking with the routine after
reading on the balcony enjoying
literature I headed up to the rooftop to
meditate and clear my head some more I
got to take a
[__] quick little 10 minute 10minute
meditation even this the style of this
video this is something extremely new to
me doing like this Mr beasti is style
where there's a lot of Storytelling and
commentating over the b-roll and stuff
that you're seeing I mean you have to
think about the logistics of this these
are tough to plan out and even something
like this quick 10-minute meditation I
was able to get so much more clarity on
the vision of it and how I want this
video to be structured like what you're
watching right now is largely based off
of like literally 10 minutes of brain
power and just sitting in breathing
which is pretty incredible to think
about how much you can come up with in
such a short amount of time and you just
limit distractions and really give your
brain the chance to [__] think bro
for like 2 seconds about music blasting
in your ears or all this
nonsense but yeah I need a [__] now took
a fire dump staring at the wall nothing
to look at in the process sorry there's
no video of it but it got my brain going
you see I'm similar to most of you guys
I literally just want to lay in bed all
day but I don't the people who run the
world Matrix Puppet Masters whatever you
want to call them they understand this
they know we're naturally lazy people
who just want to eat nut chill and lay
around so we're fed tools and Trojan
horses which bring us closer to that
monkey state of being [__] food giving
us energy crashes porn which sucks our
soul and phones which are the biggest
energy drainers of them all look you're
not tired and unenergized all the time
you're doing energy sucking activities
ever noticed how after looking at your
phone you actually feel more tired and
[__] here at day two that's
something new I learned boring myself so
much with this dopamine detox I decided
to make a mini skit inside this video a
30-minute segment of my time which
probably would have just been eaten up
by social media but instead was used to
write this and for you boring yourself
to where starting that Tik Tok page
reading that business book becomes a
[__] it there's nothing else to
do anyways back to what's going on
happening next or I don't know it's only
day two of filming this video see
you day three just woke up yesterday we
got 12 hours of sleep today we're
getting like six hit in the gym with the
personal trainer yeah I can definitely
tell it's already a lot easier getting
up right now but you can't just like
look at your phone and scroll you
actually have to like get up like make
my bed Journal do some push-ups and then
dip out it's not as bad not going to lie
it's not as bad Dave started off as
usual some push-ups journal to get a
good plan for attack morning gym session
car got towed cuz I'm an idiot and left
it in the wrong spot shely post gym I
get told bro that's like the funniest
part about the adult world is basically
every day it's just someone taking your
money like get [__] bro then before
getting into the work day met up with
the old man to revisit an old friendly
spot tell them the last time we've been
been here what were we here for you
scraping Barnacles the last time I was
at this base we're at the Miami Coast
Guard base and since my grades were [__]
in high
school and my dad was [__] pissed at
me so he sent me here to scrape
Barnacles off the belts all
day that wasn't the main purpose it was
you to see what it's like to be a listen
oh yeah yeah yeah also to see if I
wanted to join the military basically
like get [__] rest of the day same
[__] work and bored I had a new
realization though as I've had every
other day of this challenge food it's
just you grubbing looking at the food on
the fork with each bite tasting the
different flavors nowhere else for your
mind to be like meditating I had some
wise cognizant understandings I wonder
how many people are getting railed in
this building right now no but seriously
try it go to a local restaurant without
your phone grab food eat it there and
just notice how different it feels with
phones it's almost like our brains are
on iOS brain 2.0 where being present
isn't possible anyways day four
fac the
M don't be like this NPC bro pause that
don't look at these NPCs like just like
looking at their devices and stuff like
look she's looking at his phone with no
soul dude absolutely no soul and I
literally got caught stuck in a video if
you want to learn the easiest way to
make 10K a month off the creativity beta
join Sony fast Discord
yeah 100p 100 P just looking at other
people on their so while I'm still like
raping this detox it's just like damn
bro I've been vlogging on my phone
camera quality yo what's going Vlog yo
um we're out here today son's ripping a
dope me in detox and I am just giving
myself more Tik Tok brain go back to
your ti Tok so apparently they just
busted a sex trafficking ring they had
the a lot of people in the government
ripping the tugs ripping tugs yeah bro
anyways 4 days in still going going with
the routine the am raw eggs folded my
laundry no wifey to do that yet ate some
food reading a book on my computer and
that's when the challenge really started
hitting me not going to lie the the
first 3 days of this challenge were
definitely a lot easier it sounds kind
of [__] that it's tough to go even a
week without enjoying without enjoying
stuff but yeah I can I can feel the
urges creeping back in you know wanting
nicotine honestly
[__] wed to nut I can't even hang out
with girls this week like there's no way
I would uh there's no point so I had to
text them I was like I'm sorry but I'm
busy till Monday that's what I said I'm
going to be straight up with you guys
I'm struggling with this [__] right now
the sexual urges honestly like the the
urge to just consume some content or
something like I haven't done it in the
last 4 days and it's just getting so
[__] boring I've just been reading a
ton meditating I don't know so I'm going
to go on a run right now I got to clear
my [__] head cuz right now I want to
hit up a
girl going on a run late at night like
this reminds you of why you do what you
do all the [__] that told you
you wouldn't be able to do it those
[__] teachers who would laugh at you
cuz you were studying some other stuff
in class you're not paying attention to
their [__] your parents who never
took you seriously those friends who
told you to basically get [__] that
girl who never looked at you got to just
feed off of that [__] that's what keeps
me going for [__] for a while I would
read those [__] what they did to me
in the mirror every day every morning
and night I would remember who the [__]
were proving wrong whose Souls were
taking and right now I'm feeling it bro
as I'm like I'm up in my my room and my
desk about to get a girl over about to
look at social media those sounds like
little dumb [__] it means a lot to me
right now I say [__] that and I go on a
run and clear my head look where I am
right now I'm in [__] Miami I wasn't
supposed to be here I'm 20 years old
living in a place that cost me 6 grand a
month [__] what am I what am I doing
here cannot let the opinions of those
who whose lives you don't want to live
affect you I hear it every single day
from the kids I went to high school with
from family members telling you you
don't know what you're talking about
they're smarter they're wiser than you
you know what you tell them get [__]
that's what you tell them if you want to
do a dopamine detox for a week and
people laugh at you cuz you don't want
to hit their Vape or you don't want to
drink a [__] Corona tell them to get
[__] you're on a different path people
in the 1% do 1% [__] bro I'm literally
going on a run at 10 of the night right
now like a [__] idiot everyone's out
drinking and having fun you make up your
path bro I get it it might be [__]
hard if there's anyone that can do it
it's you bro trust me I've been I've
been there I know what it's like when No
One Believes In You And Everything feels
[__] there's always chest moves you
can make to get out of it bro this city
man you would have told me 3 years ago
when I was playing fortnite that I'd be
going on a run in Miami to clear my head
in my apartment and then I would have
told you you're [__] insane but also
I wouldn't cuz I knew this was the
plan jog my Walmart goggin's ass back
home to get ready for bed but before
going to sleep I actually have my first
cheat of the week which I've known was
coming the kid L Roy has been my top
artist for a few years now and he just
dropped a new album turn around and say
[__] my principal and Dro down I'm not
going to be like other influencers
faking [__] I'll be real there was no
way I was waiting another 3 days however
no deed goes unpunished as you'll see so
this is my first time where I really
cheated getting any dopamine in the last
4 days since starting the challenge but
honestly you know I've been waiting for
this album for like 2 years now so I
don't really care what are you going to
do I really want to listen to it but in
a way I'm almost grateful that this
album came out in a time where I'm doing
this dopamine detox because for such a
long period of time when you're going
through the process of scrolling through
social media and your your receptors are
fried there's periods where like I'd be
scrolling through music in my car and
nothing would be hitting like everything
would sound dull and you would just want
to keep skipping to the next song to get
that dopamine rush and you'd go through
like 10 songs and nothing would do it
for you and I'm sure a lot of you guys
felt that same thing that I did did but
since over the past few days I've been
practicing being bored so much just
being there with my thoughts waiting for
the elevator just sitting there looking
at the button now that I'm listening to
the music it's almost like a year ago
when I would smoke weed 2 years ago I I
don't really smoke anymore but when I
used to smoke weed and listen to music
and you'd hear all the different
Melodies I almost I feel like that now
just because I've been able to reset my
brain so that I'm able to enjoy the
smaller things more so the different
guitar strums the different beat
switches Melodies lyrics I'm able to
take it in more like how I would where I
would have to get high back in the day
to have the same level of enjoyment so
it's pretty crazy I I didn't even I
didn't realize how much I missed music
either until I started this challenge as
well like how often I would just be
doing something like a chore or work or
literally anything and I would have
music on in the background so many times
in the past few days where I've wanted
to turn something on while I'm doing a
task and I just can't because I'm doing
this detox but yeah like I said this is
my first time cheating and with me
cheating I of course want a punishment
you know I want to be fair for this so
tomorrow I'll be sitting outside of my
balcony with no distractions basically
meditating for 2 hours straight so yeah
that'll be fun I'm
sure here I am 5 days no social media
nutting nicotine or alcohol I can now
see my farts the seen held in has formed
into webs turning me into black
Spider-Man 100% serious of course as you
know yesterday was my first and only
time cheating listening to the Kinder
album it reminded me of how quickly
external forces can stick to your psyche
and distract you from your true self
just like the black
Spider-Man sitting out here now trying
to disconnect from this world of pain
and I song lyrics from yesterday
non-stop running through my brain the
longest I've gone without none is a
month and a half but ended after hearing
whack I could jerk look you into the
eyes and laugh One Clip end of the
streak one time thing yeah sure tell
yourself same thing every day that week
remembering back when you were pure that
one first decision makes pain a gain
wrong move you're a slave to your urg is
a gain day five of the detox resetting
the brain after this [__] will never be
the same out on the balcony looking up
in the sky man all I can do is thank
that [__] guy as I'm writing this
[__] [__] blowing up my phone
downstairs Zer and HS throwing shots to
the Dome man these Cloud [__] really
got to go home 20 years old top fluent
Mia go tell those [__] from my town
see what they say lying ass fools in
high school ripping Jewels yeah now look
who's cool
[__] moving on to day six
I guess that's it for this see you in
the next [__] little
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] so what I've been doing all week
is a dopamine detox where it's like you
don't [__] know social media nutting
nicotine alcohol like you can't do
anything that's fun and so um at the end
of day four I ended up listening to like
an album which is my first time cheating
and then the next day I punish myself by
going on the balcony of my crib for for
2 hours with just a notebook just like
it was like detention but then like
while I was out there I had like the
song beat running through my head so
then I ended up just like writing these
lyrics for it and that's why I'm here
today cuz like the day five of me
showing this uh journey of my dopamine
detox is going to be in like the song
and then just me talking about it
hopefully it's uh it goes hard we'll see
recording the detox song was honestly a
blast pretty crazy how at any moment you
can do literally anything you can go get
punched in the face book a recording
studio drive to the other side of the
country literally anything anyways after
recording did some more fishing got
dinner with a couple guys but one of
them eats his food raw bro how is it
pretty good
cheers R
meat there we
go how is it no
flavor that's cuz your mouth isn't
seasoned
yet what am I supposed to season it with
[__] long long day fun getting out
there moving around the GTA map ended
the day with some journaling and
reflecting and on to the last
day 7 Days of boring myself to death I
went fishing shaved my beard made a rap
song never thought I'd tap into my 2%
nth sah and realized I'm better than
everyone joking well not really rather
than toting my own horn I'll explain how
all of you can be better than everyone
too without a phone
you see how every [__] alive
whips theirs out at any millisecond they
need to wait food lines walking your
friend gets boring the elevator Katie I
know there isn't service in here what
the [__] are you looking at from this
last week my biggest wisest realization
to truly get ahead
is have a normal
brain that's it a brain where you can
sit with a notebook and come up with an
idea where you can read for 30 minutes
without needing an Instagram scroll to
feed your dopamine where you can go on a
run without blasting the same song in
your ear for the thousandth time that
day it's amazing how much more you can
get done in the day without the classic
IG story to Twitter back to ig story
mindless routine I've been wanting to
make music for years and my first song
ended up being a 24-hour process you yes
you I see through the camera you sitting
on the [__] watching this video right
after you drop a sub and like the video
go stare at a wall for 30 minutes and
tell me how exciting working on your
business sounds or even starting your
first it can start today there is no
tomorrow stop giving all your energy to
Mr can't believe this started in my
parents garage wake
[Music]
up I see the Bad Moon
Rising I see trouble on the
way I see hurcan
[Music]
lightning I see bad times
today don't go around tonight but if B
to take your
[Music]
life